la siguiente línea pasa por el punto
menos 52 ok por este punto y tiene como
ecuación y es igual a 8 entre 11 esto x
x más ve cuál es el valor de la
intersección con el eje de las yes o b y
bueno lo que nosotros sabemos es que
este punto debe de satisfacer esta
ecuación como este punto está en esta
recta entonces debe de satisfacer esta
ecuación eso quiere decir que cuando x
vale menos cinco cuando x vale menos 5
entonces ya vale 2 entonces que vale 2 y
entonces podemos decir que 2 qe2 estoy
sustituyendo aquí 2 es igual a quien a
bueno es igual a 8 entre 11 ok esto que
a su vez multiplica a x pero
al menos 5 o que estoy sustituyendo
estos valores de este punto en esta
ecuación ya esto le voy a sumar déjame
ponerlo cuando este color
a esto le voy a sumar ven y
esencialmente lo que tenemos que hacer
es despejar ab resuelve esta ecuación
para b y bueno para eso lo primero que
puedo hacer es reducir un poco esta
expresión porque aquí me quedaría 2 es
igual a 8 entre 11 x menos 5 bueno pues
eso es lo mismo que menos 5 x 8 40 40
entre 11 ok ya esto hay que sumarle b a
esto hay que sumarle b y bueno como
queremos despejar a b entonces a esta
fracción la voy a pasar del otro lado y
para pasarla del otro lado lo que voy a
hacer es sumar de ambos lados a la misma
cantidad que va a ser 40 entre 11
entonces esto me va a quedar 2
y dos más
más es decir que va a ser 40 entre 11 40
entre 11 ok esto es igual a menos 40
entre 11 más 40 entre 11 bueno pues eso
se va y solamente me queda b
ok y ahora lo único que nos falta es
hacer la operación que tenemos aquí con
fracciones y para eso déjame bajar un
poco la pantalla ok y vamos a seguir el
problema en cuanto es 2 expresado como
una fracción que tenga denominador 11
bueno pues esto es lo mismo
y déjenme ponerlo con este color 2 por
11 es 22 a 22 entre 11 ok ya esto le voy
a sumar 40 entre 11 ok
40 entre 11 y con esto voy a obtener el
valor de ven pero bueno esto lo mismo
que a 22 más 40 no es lo mismo que 62 62
entre 11 entonces me va a quedar 62
entre 11 y bueno esto es lo mismo que el
valor de b
y perfecto como ya tenemos a bien
entonces puedo decir que la ecuación de
esta recta es bien es igual a 8 entre 11
8 entre 11 por equis ya esto le sumamos
b más ve que 62 entre 11 más 62 entre 11